بصوت وقلب واحد يردد التلاميذ السعوديون
مع مدرسهم اغنيه وطني الحبيب هذه الاغنيه
الشهيره للراحل طلال مداح في فيديو انتشر
بشكل ملفت على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اللوح الوطنيه التي رسمها التلاميذ مع
المدرس السعودي
الطلاب عبروا عن حبهم لبلادهم بفكره بسيطه
ومن خلال اغنيه لطالما رددها السعوديون في
احتفالاتهم الوطنيه اليوم سنكون مع المدرس
عبد الله الغامدي
يحفظه
وارضاه
الحبيب هو
انت مولود العزه
نورنا المعلم عبد الله الغامدي عبد الله
اهلا بك يسعد صباحك شكرا على تواجدك معانا
منورنا بصباح العربيه
صباح النور والسرور شكرا لكم على
الاستضافه اهلا
بك مقطع فيديو تشارك فيه الطلاب اغنيه
وطني الحبيب الراحل طلال مداح حصل تفاعلا
كبيرا على مواقع التواصل لو تحدثنا اولا
عن فكره هذا الفيديو وتسجيله
اولا اقول وطن قام على عبد العزيز ورجاله
فرفعه العزيز بافضاله واستمر بطموح المجد
واماله
بخصوص المقطع كانت الفكره بسيطه ولكن
معانيها كبيره وهي غير صروح الوطنيه لدى
الطلاب منذ الصغر فالعلم في الصغر كالنكش
على الحجر وهذه رساله كل معلم ومعلم فنحن
نصنع قاده ونحن نصنع قاده صناع الحياه
لمستقبل مشرق وهذه رساله كل معلم ومعلمه
ونحقق طموح سيدي ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان
رؤيه 2030 نعم يعني وهكذا نزرع في ابنائنا
في جيل الغد حب الوطن اليوم استاذ عبد
الله لاحظت انه في حماس كبير جدا لديكم
انت تصور وتحمل هذا الهاتف وبتصور نفسك
والتلاميذ هل حبيت انه تشجع الطلاب على
امر ما تشجعهم انه ينطلقوا بتعبير في حبهم
على الوطن من خلال هذه الاغنيه
نعم
نعم الطالب المعلم كلما كسر الحاجز بينه
وبين الطالب والطالب احب المعلم حتما سيحب
الماده التي يقدمها له وكذلك سيبدا ستظهر
الموهبه وهذا انا ما حبيت اني اوصله
لابناء الطلاب وكذلك ازرع فيهم روح
الوطنيه
طب استاذ عبد الله هل توقعتم هذا التفاعل
الكبير وهذا الانتشار الكبير للفيديو على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وكل الاعجابات به
توفيق الله ثم الاخلاص في العمل والنيه
الطيبه وصل هذا وصل هذا العمل الى شريحه
كبيره من
الناس والدليل تناقل في وسائل التواصل
السوشيال ميديا القنوات التلفزيونيه وهذا
شيء مشرف ويعتبر انجاز
والاصدقاء اليوم في صباح العربيه على شاشه
العربيه واضافه اضافه وانا مستمتع جدا
طب يا استاذ لماذا اخترت كمان اغنيه هل
تعتقد انه الاغنيه اسهل وفعاله وقعها اكثر
لطلاب من انك مثلا تعطيهم ديوان شعري او
اقوال في حب الوطن
ممكن لاني انا متاثر فيها من الجيل
التسعينات متاثر فيها
وهي اغنيه معنا من ذي الصغر فحبيت اني
اقدمها لهم بطريقه جميله والحمد لله انها
وصلت للجميع طيب استاذ عبد الله تعلم
طلابك معنا الوطنيه وحب الوطن ماذا تقولون
عن الوطن في يومه الكبير يوم التاسيس
اقول حفظ الله قادتنا حفظ الله الملك
سلمان ووليه عهد محمد بن سلمان والشعب
السعودي كافه واقول
انقلوا ماضينا وحاضرنا بصوره ايجابيه وفخر
واعتزاز وشموخ الى كل الشعوب في يوم تاسيس
الوطن
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر على ظهورك ووجودك
معنا شكرا لك من جدا المعلم عبد الله
الغامدي الذي انتشر له هذا الفيديو الشهير
مع التلاميذ وهم يرددون ويغنون اغنيه وطني
الحبيب هذه الاغنيه الشهيره للراحل طلال
مداح في ذكرى يوم التاسيس من جده شكرا
جزيلا للمعلم عبد الله الغامدي شكرا لك
استاذ عبد الله